webb gaza gaza oui cette cave et ceux
qui aiment le toit et promis bat a
failli me faisais ça aquaplaning joue
l'agglo d'agde bluetooth à bourgoin
ofakim canario passe à déboucher salaf l
onu cadiou sa galette à canala les
habitants de fondeurs vivent dans un
stress quotidien sur la rocade
ce panneau indique une chaussée
glissante mais rien n'y fait chaque jour
les riverains sont témoins du ballet
d'accidents incessants hier soir ça fait
un bout il vraiment infernal où les ja
et 2 sont amenés à sortir de chez eux
pour venir voir parce que le bruit que
l'accident au bout qui s'est produit au
moment de l'accident vraiment sa frappe
et les gens voient ce été obligés de se
déplacer pour venir voir ce qui s'est
passé au bord de la rocade nous trouvons
en effet ce canal d'eau stagnante qui ne
peut sans doute pas s'écouler
normalement dans une buse sous la
chaussée même par temps sec l'eau
déborde alors au milieu de la
circulation au point de former de la
mousse le véhicule des rapts alors
facilement made in toulouse où les
responsabilités sont elles partagées
entre la ctm responsable des routes et
la ville de fort de france
en attendant le voisinage perd patience
je me pose la question est-ce qu'ils
sont méchants
est ce que veulent pas le faire où ils
sont fous des gens qui habitent ici il
ya plein de choses
c'est normalement déjà fait passionnant
ça devait se faire
la méchanceté
ça fait très pur confiance a fait
sursauter surtout passionnante à
l'avoine les coucheries et après c'est
le beau et on imagine vraiment cassé
soit un accident montel soit c'est
beaucoup de blessés c'est par quand même
évident tant le bruit est d'aller voir
et puis pour voir si c'est un enfant
ce personnage est parce que nous sommes
tous concernés
quelle est donc la nature des travaux à
réaliser ici pour rétablir la sécurité
en attendant la prudence impose à tous
de lever le pied à cet endroit précis
mais pas seulement